[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour cette
troisième saison du 7-8 europe sur tv
60,18 évolution minimale pour cette
nouvelle saison avec désormais deux
parties la première enregistrée ici au
parlement européen de bruxelles ce mois
ci nous sommes en compagnie de
l'eurodéputé franciliens membres du
mouvement générations guillaume balas
nous évoquerons avec lui la très large
et très compliqué questions migratoires
qui semblent divisés plus que jamais
l'europe nous feront le pont aussi sur
le break site neuf mois avant la sortie
du royaume uni de l'union européenne six
mois plus tôt les vingt-sept semble
cette fois-ci soudés pour le pire
enfin à quelques mois des élections
européennes une nouveauté dans le 7-8
europe
dans la seconde partie de l'émission
vous découvrirez l'action de l'union
européenne en ile de france avec
notamment un reportage dans l'une des
structures qui a profité des
financements des fonds européens
nous irons ce mois ci à melun en
seine-et-marne pour découvrir un centre
d'affaires pour les quartiers une
aubaine pour les jeunes porteurs de
projets parfois un peu perdu dans
l'univers impitoyable de
l'entrepreneuriat
[Musique]
guillaume balas bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes eurodéputés franciliens depuis 2014
vous siégez ici au sein du groupe des
socialistes et démocrates groupe que
l'on peut comparer pour vulgariser en
france au ps pour autant vous n'êtes
plus membre du ps depuis près d'un an
vous avez rejoint le mouvement
générations créé par benoît hamon
c'était en novembre 2010 est vous êtes
aujourd'hui le coordinateur du mouvement
est-ce que vous avez aussi songé à
quitter le groupe ici socialiste au
parlement européen
ce qui est sûr en tout cas c'est que il
va falloir tout changer dans la
géographie politique du parlement
européen
je crois que les groupes tels qu'ils
existent notamment à gauche socialistes
verts et gauche radicale ne
correspondent à plus rien nos corps et
des clivages ne sont plus les bons vous
avez des libéraux chez les socialistes
des libéraux chez les verts vous avez
des souverainistes dans la gauche
radicale et d'autres qui sont très
pro-européens bref ces groupes ne sont
d'accord sur rien en réalité et donc il
est très important de créer autre chose
d'innovant groupe idées de gauche
écologistes démocrates social pro
européen mais contre la l'union
européenne telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui
c'est à dire ultra libéral productiviste
et anti-écologique et je crois que ce
que oui il sait aujourd'hui ce que doit
être la gauche si elle veut être utile à
l'europe autrement ne sert pas à grand
chose ce serait une gauche à l'image du
mouvement générations d'aujourd'hui
c'est ce que nous voulons tenter
effectivement on voit bien d'ailleurs
dans plusieurs pays il n'y a pas qu'en
france que de nouveaux mouvements de
gauche existe je pense à la pologne avec
hrazem par exemple qui ne se
reconnaissent plus j'allais dire dans
l'échec de la social démocratie qui a
tellement c'est tellement compromis avec
la droite au niveau européen
qu'aujourd'hui c'est très compliqué
d'avoir une légitimité et qui en même
temps rejette le souverainisme et
populistes nationalistes qui est en
train de monter donc être de gauche
écologistes européens c'est ça la voie à
guillaume balas l'actualité du moment
ces deux actualités principal le bric
site avec ces tensions qui perdurent
entre l'union européenne et theresa may
qui se trouvent en difficulté avec
l'union européenne mais aussi à
l'intérieur chez elle et puis aussi la
question migratoire et l'europe qui se
divisent toujours plus sur ce sujet
qu'est ce qui vous en tant que
aux députés membres de génération vous
interpelle le plus vous fait le plus
réagir bien la chose suivante c'est que
à la fin du 19e siècle au début du 20e
siècle l'europe avait une démographie
très importante un nombre d'enfants par
femme très important et donc nous avons
conquis la planète par le biais de la
colonisation par d'autres biais aussi
nous avons installé des populations à
l'extérieur et aujourd'hui nous ne
comprendrions pas que des continents
entiers tels que l'afrique par exemple
se trouve dans la situation que nous
avons connue et donc qui a des poussée
migratoire qui sont fortes
dhaussy il faut regarder d'abord la
réalité il y aura des migrations
c'est à dire que ceux qui pensent qu'on
peut mettre une europe forteresse où
personne ne rentre seul heures les
médias la vérité aux gens d'écrire dans
ces sites sans barbelés des frontières
et des murs arrêteront les migrations ça
n'a jamais existé dans l'histoire ça
n'existera pas pire ça apportera des
catastrophes parce que nous allons créer
de la frustration sur des continents
entiers qui ici aujourd'hui ils sont
dans un développement économique
compliqué vont devenir de plus en plus
puissants dans les décennies qui
viennent donc il faut organiser de
manière rationnelle mesurer et avec un
esprit de fraternité
ces migrations ça ressemblerait quoi
justement bien valorisé j'abhorre
premiers éléments c'est reconnaître
quand il ya des réfugiés qui sont des
réfugiés politiques qu'ils ont un droit
spécifique
ça c'est le premier point le deuxième
point c'est que les réfugiés climatiques
doivent avoir aussi droit à des éléments
d'accueil particulier parce que ils ne
peuvent pas faire autrement que de
partir de chez eux
et enfin il ya la question migratoire
lié aux questions économiques
je pense que c'est un mensonge de dire
que on peut arrêter totalement la
migration économique
c'est faux ça n'a jamais existé dans
l'histoire du monde et donc nous ferions
mieux de l'organiser avec les pays de
départ pour faire en sorte qu'elles
profitent le mieux ce n'est pas exact et
les discussion à vingt-sept clairement
aujourd'hui je vais arriver à cela mais
par exemple on s'aperçoit que quand on
donne un droit à des gens d'aller retour
avec leur pays d'origine ils
s'installent moins dans l'est
pays dans lesquels ils ont migré il
retourne plus qu'en en revanche on ne
donne pas de droits que les gens sont
dans l'attenté seen it et travaille de
manière clandestine
évidemment ils repartent moins donc on
voit bien qu'en plus on est sur des
fausses des fausses solutions que
doit-on faire au niveau européen on voit
bien qu'il n'ya pas d'accord au niveau
excellence ça semble un peu cela
aujourd'hui entre il faut dans l'est et
l'ouest pour résumer le sol et
rapidement il faut quand même se battre
au maximum pour expliquer que ce doit
être aujourd'hui au niveau européen que
se traite cette question il est
totalement inenvisageable de penser que
simplement au niveau national nous
puissions réguler des flux migratoires
et enfin dans un deuxième temps si nous
n'y arrivons pas avec l'ensemble des
pays européens
rien ne nous interdit de faire des
coopérations renforcées sur le sujet et
la france a été très coupable sous
monsieur hollande et souffre aujourd'hui
monsieur macron de ne pas avoir proposé
cette coopération renforcée avec
l'italie par exemple
et qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui par exemple avec viktor
orban nous certains pays de l'est qui ne
veulent pas jouer le jeu d'une réforme
de la politique migratoire comment leurs
forces à main justement des biens en
fait si vous souhaitez en étant
exemplaire c'est à dire que vous
comprenez bien que monsieur max en
accueillant des migrants par exemple on
va attendre l'avis fait rigoler en tout
cas monsieur mac ont fait rigoler la
planète entière et notamment l'europe
entière notamment dans les pays de l'est
quand il dit où la lame sur ban il est
très très méchant il est contre les
migrants vous regardez le nombre
notamment de migrants aujourd'hui
accueillis en france qui est ridicule
par rapport à l'italie
le fait qu'on décourage au maximum la
migration qu'on ne cherche pas à
l'organiser encore une fois tout en
étant raisonnable à mai mais de
l'organiser nous perdons absolument
toute crédibilité au niveau européen
donc la question si on veut vraiment
aujourd'hui combattre monsieur or ban
c'est de dire nous prenons en charge
aujourd'hui ces questions migratoires
nous les organisons nous proposer ce
sont des coopérations renforcées à
l'italie l'espagne la grèce l'allemagne
les pays bas ce qui se fait et bien sûr
est justement une dernière question sur
ce sujet les pays qui selon vous
pourrait se prêter au jeu en neuf et
différent maintenant les images et les
biens vie va être très bel essai il a
pris la tête du medh sans doute que avec
l'espagne le portugal avec
la belgique avec les pays bas il y
aurait quelque chose à faire si vous
pensez que sur ce sujet l'union
européenne peut se fracasser se diviser
alors c'est une expression qu'on emploie
depuis très longtemps eu la crise
financière la crise monétaire
désormais je crois peut commander à la
dissolution de l'union européenne je
pense que cette thèse n'existe pas je
pense que ça peut être encore pire c'est
une forme d'implosion c'est à dire qu'on
garde le cadre du libéralisme économique
et que par contre il y à un retour à la
souveraineté nationale pour à peu près
tout le reste c'est à dire en gros ça va
être le dumping social généralisé le
dumping fiscal généralisée et en plus
des politiques répressives contre les
migrants mais aussi contre les
populations comme elle se développe on
voit hongrie ou en pologne contre les
droits civiques
donc il faut faire extrêmement attention
ce n'est pas tant l'union européenne qui
est menacée d'éclatement que ces valeurs
même et le fait qu un ultralibéralisme
nationaliste puisse finalement remporté
la mise en europe alors là on parle de
parties de leaders politiques de pays
mais comment rassure finalement les
populations parce que finalement
généralement les dirigeants jouent la
carte des populations qui ont peur comme
on rassure les gens pour leur dire que
finalement le problème migratoire ça va
déjà arrivé pour être à cette franchise
dont vous parliez puis aussi pour les
rassurer pour leur dire que leur
quotidien ne va pas être chamboulée
quand vous organisez pas les choses elle
se développe de manière anarchique et et
sauvage et donc effectivement c'est dans
les quartiers populaires aujourd'hui
vous subissez le plus les questions
migratoires de manière non organisé ça
crée des tensions
si vous avez une approche qui est une
approche organisé où on demande la
solidarité à tous le corps de la nation
et toutes ses classes sociales
souvenez-vous comme à paris il a été
difficile de mettre un centre pour sdf
dans le 16e arrondissement par exemple
eh bien si toutes les classes sociales
étaient solidaires sur ce sujet on
verrait que les migrations sont peu
importantes en nombre en réalité
beaucoup diminué l on vit beaucoup
diminué et que il ya beaucoup de
fantasmes
mais comme ces migrations se concentrent
dans certains quartiers certaines zones
aujourd'hui évidemment que ça crée des
tensions et b et des problèmes autre
sujet d'actualité le break site là au
contraire il semble y avoir une entente
entre les vingt-sept pour ne rien céder
aux britanniques
c'est finalement un peu c'est paradoxal
mais dans le divorce que lui ait fait
preuve de solidarité comment vous jugez
là aussi la situation du bric cité ce
qu'il faudrait continuer sur ce chemin
là avec theresa may il dira qu on ne
cédera rien ou alors lui tendre la main
l'a aussi il faut dire que les
britanniques se sont mis dans une
situation très difficile et il est très
compliqué de leur tendre la main comme
cela mais j'aurais quand même faire une
remarque le grand fantasme qui est ce
sera mieux sans le royaume-uni notamment
pour la france dans l'europe qui vient
aujourd'hui est à mon avis mortifère
pourquoi parce que nous laissons une
place notamment à l'allemagne et à une
volonté de puissance allemande
aujourd'hui dans les institutions mais
aussi du point de vue économique sans
équilibre et je crois que le royaume uni
était quand même un moyen d'équilibré
pour nous français cette puissance
allemande
donc je pense qu'il faut quand même
veiller à ne pas en faire trop
est-ce que c'est l'occasion pour
certains pays comme l'espagne ou
l'italie de prendre aussi une autre vue
notre place au sein du conseil européen
et puis arrêtez peut-être ce mythe du
couple franco-allemand qui passe je sois
d'accord avec vous si nous ne continuons
pas ce couple
ce mythe du couple franco allemand mais
malheureusement il perdure on le voit
bien et je crois que c'est sans lien en
réalité avec la question de nos liens
avec le royaume uni ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que si le royaume uni
continuent de préférer le break site
il ne faut pas non plus annuler toutes
nos chances d'avoir un partenariat
pacifiques et amicales je n'aimerais pas
que le royaume uni se transforme en une
vaste plate forme de dumping fiscal et
social qui fasse de souvenirs intimes de
la vie d'aujourd'hui theresa may et
l'union européenne être du coup raisons
selon vous de rester faire mal
simplement il faut faire attention parce
que uniquement les services en avoir du
marché unix et voilà il faut faire
attention parce que si l on ne peut pas
accepter de la part de theresa may
d'avoir les avantages et l'union
européenne sans aucune contrainte à voir
l'union européenne totalement en dehors
je vais dire de l'union européenne en
termes de relations économiques
c'est aussi un danger parce qu'ils
peuvent jouer la carte du pire puisque
vous seriez favorable vous par exemple à
un second vote c'est une musique on
entend de plus en plus monsieur les
britanniques ont fait ce choix souverain
de quitter l'union européenne et il
n'appartient qu'à eux de faire le choix
souverain d revenir
les eurosceptiques semble aussi
s'intéresser à ce sujet a joué ce cas
cette carte est et l'argument du
regardez ils veulent faire payer les
britanniques et leur volonté populaire
est ce que vous pensez que le bric site
pourrait jouer en faveur des euro
sceptiques en 2019
en revanche je crois pas je crois que
c'est un contre exemple qui montre bien
que quitter l'union européenne et en
aucun cas une solution alors certes on
dit l'économie britannique ne s'est pas
effondré c'est parfaitement juste le
seul problème c'est qu'on voit le
désordre politique installé dans le
royaume uni est aujourd'hui le manque de
stratégie pour le futur que chris osgood
avec l'union européenne ont exactement
donc non je crois pas que ce soit un
argument pour les populistes d'ailleurs
un petit mot sur ces populistes
je pense que quand on est nationaliste
la première chose c'est qu'on ne se fait
pas j'allais dire instruire par monsieur
ban qui était conseiller de monsieur
trump et qui est américain
et quand même un paradoxe avoir des
nationalistes pro américains aujourd'hui
est ce que ce sera ça là la bataille de
mai 2019 les nationalistes contre on va
dire les europhiles
ils ont ça veut rien dire il n'a aucun
sens commerce et l'ont privé c'est vrai
il ya une excellente tribune qui est
sorti là dessus moi je suis pro européen
mais mon europe n'a rien à voir avec
celle de monsieur macro rien à voir avec
celle de madame merkel rien à voir avec
celle de monsieur je pense que si de
jouer ce jeu ils ont intérêt l'un de
l'autre
si vous voulez les libéraux qui
aujourd'hui ont détruit l'europe
à force d'un manque de solidarité en
terme social et d'avoir laissé les
riches faire absolument ce qu'ils
voulaient du point de vue fiscal ont
produit le populisme et de nationalisme
notamment après la crise de 2008 et les
uns ont besoin des autres les
nationalistes peuvent taper sur macro et
macro on peut taper sur une nationale
ici alors pour la gauche aujourd'hui
vous direz si si si ce ne sont pas les
orientations aujourd'hui qui sont celles
que nous portons c'est à dire d'une
europe solidaire qui remporte la mise
alors là pour le coup il y aura 10
solutia beaucoup de travail à faire
d'ici six mois parce que après les
sondages sont ceux qui le sont mais il
semble pas en tout cas favorables
aujourd'hui à à cette gauche
progressiste que vous aviez vous verra
vous savez qu'en quelques jours avant le
front populaire personne n'imaginait que
la gauche les transformer profondément
le pays ait accordé autant de protection
ou aux salariés on sait jamais comment
l'histoire va avancer il faut déjà le
vouloir de quelle gauche on parle en
tout cas en france puisque après on
verra l'échelle européen mais de quelle
gauche on parle est ce qu'on parle de
génération avec les verts comme à la
présidentielle avec le parti communiste
avec la france insoumise même si ça
semble très compliqué on est on est
encore à des mois de l'élection
européenne je pense que déjà chacun doit
affirmer son projet pour voir en quoi on
peut avoir des convergences et des
divergences c'est vrai que il ya des
convergences assez évidente avec les
écologistes même si nous pouvons aussi
on ne peut pas rester simplement sur un
projet stricto sensu écologistes il faut
aussi s'adresser aux gens sur la
question sociale
il risque de ne pas adhérer avec la
france insoumise le débat est un petit
peu différent c'est que c'est à dire une
idée où ça bloque sur les personnages la
france non non non non c'est vraiment
sur les idées il ya une question de
grand flou on voit bien qu'on joue un
peu du resort nationaliste
l'indépendantisme la france on comprend
pas bien ce que ça veut dire
on dit que l'on veut sortir des traités
mais on dit en même temps que ça c'est
pas pour les élections européennes qu'on
va en parler alors là c'est encore plus
floue ici on parle pas de la question de
sortir ou pas des traités au moment de
la question européenne
on ne voit pas et en tout cas nous ne
prendrons pas le risque de la sortie
l'union nous nous pensons que le site a
démontré que c'était une fausse solution
le parti communiste aussi semblait y
avoir une entente en tout cas on l'a vu
nous discutons bien parti communiste
parce que le parti communiste a une
vision qui est une vision qui nous
intéresse sur le fait que c'est en
organisant justement les salariés qui
subissent au dumping social aujourd'hui
dans toute l'union européenne contre
ceux qui les exploitent et notamment ses
grandes multinationales qui organise ce
de pin social qu'on fera avancer la
cause européenne et non pas en opposant
les peuples les uns aux autres
dernière question alors on le sait pour
les prochaines élections européennes y
aura une liste nationale plus de listes
régionales comme comme aujourd'hui vous
êtes peut-être l'un des derniers aux
députés franciliens mais est ce que vous
serez encore candidat aux prochaines
élections européennes guillaume balas
rabat en tout cas je proposerai ma
candidature à mon mouvement j'en
discuterai avec lui c'est lui qui
choisira merci guillaume balas d'avoir
répondu à nos questions
on va continuer désormais cette émission
dans les studios de tv 60 18 mai avant
pour continuer aussi sur la thématique
migratoires nous allons voir comment
globalement cette thématique est géré
par nos voisins européens l'origine des
migrants les principaux pays d'accueil
en europe ont fait le point avec olivier
jeanne l'ex responsable du centre europe
direct à saint germain en laye
[Musique]
on a constaté concernant l'origine des
migrants que cette origine a évolué au
cours de la crise migratoire si au début
de la crise migratoire les migrants
étaient davantage l'issue du
moyen-orient on constate que sur les
dernières années ce sont davantage des
ce sont davantage des personnes venant
d'afrique notamment de tout ce qui est
erythréen soudan algérie tunisie libye
qui viennent qui tentent de migrer en or
entre les principaux pays qui
accueillent des migrants sont
l'allemagne la france l'italie la suède
l'autriche et le royaume uni les pays
qui accueillent les migrants les
accueils pour différentes raisons
certains pays par exemple comme la
france les accueils parce qu'ils ont une
parce qu'ils ont une tradition
d'ailleurs humaniste et notamment de
respect de droits de l'homme et des
minorités
on a d'autres pays par exemple qui comme
l'allemagne l'a à notamment accueilli un
certain nombre de migrants afin de va
dire lutter contre le vieillissement de
de lutter contre le vieillissement de sa
population
concernant donc le cas de la grèce de
l'italie et de la suède ce sont des pays
qui accueillent des migrants en vertu du
respect des réglementations européennes
alors l'italie et la grèce parce que ce
sont ce qu'on appelle les pays de
premier accueil et la suède notamment
parce que c'est un pays qui a
keep qui acceptent des migrants dans le
cadre du mécanisme de relocalisation les
aides dont peuvent disposer les migrants
dépendent de chaque état en règle
générale ce qu'on constate c'est que les
états mettent généralement à disposition
des migrants de type de type dead une
première aide qui est une sorte d'
allocation de subsistance et la deuxième
qui est une possibilité d'accéder au
logement
par contre pour pouvoir demander à
bénéficier de ces aides les migrants
doivent déposer une demande d'asile
[Musique]
la deuxième partie de cette émission
enregistrée sur le plateau de tv 78 dans
les yvelines
nous allons vous montrer désormais
comment l'union européenne agit
concrètement en région et plus
précisément en région francilienne
comment son action se décline dans votre
vie quotidienne pour tenter de réduire
les inégalités préserver l'environnement
ou encore pour développer l éducation
pour y parvenir l'union européenne met à
disposition des fonds spéciaux ils sont
appelés simplement les fonds européens
et permettent de soutenir la création de
nombreux projets c'est le cas par
exemple ici à saint quentin en yvelines
nous allons le voir dans quelques
instants avec notre journaliste mais
aussi en seine-et-marne où
l'agglomération de melun val de seine a
pu financer la construction de deux
centres d'affaires pour les quartiers
sur place des jeunes entrepreneurs ont
accès à toutes les informations
nécessaires pour réussir le lancement de
leur projet reportage
[Musique]
à fils c'est pour le prêt d'honneur
prêts d'honneur la garantie surpoids
bancaire d'accord bâtir tuyau est un
genre de super conseiller
sa principale mission est d'aider ces
jeunes entrepreneurs dans leurs
premières démarches et notamment pour
une opération toujours sensible est de
décrocher un prêt auprès d'une banque
on a pris l'engagement en le disant là
si vous le donner une réponse claire par
rapport à l'acceptation du crédit du
crédit
nous on vous assure qu'on travaillera
ensemble
c'est dans ces locaux neufs de 200 m²
ouverts depuis le mois d'avril que les
jeunes porteurs de projets du territoire
de melun peuvent venir développer leurs
idées ils peuvent aussi bénéficier de
rendez vous personnalisés pour apprendre
à déchiffrer le monde souvent complexes
de l'entrepreneuriat et l'idée et
l'esprit de l'atelier c'est que
l'information qui est diffusée puisse
être accessible à tous donc en gros
qu'on soit titulaire d'un ca paix ou
d'un bac + 5
l'objectif est d'expliquer très
simplement c'est quoi par exemple
l'essayer sur les incidences fiscales
sociales et on arrive on essaye
d'arriver à ce que tout le monde puisse
comprendre le fonctionnement de la
future structure qu'elle vous qu'elle
utilisera ouvert depuis six mois ce
centre d'affaires a su trouver son
public et répondre à un véritable besoin
dans les quartiers placé en politique de
la ville lancement d'un fou trucks d'un
restaurant ou d'un concept store près
d'une soixantaine d'entrepreneurs du
territoire ont ainsi pu accélérer le
développement de leurs projets trouver
des gens pour nous aider à faire le
business plan
du temps pour le faire ce genre de
choses je pense pas qu'on aurait trouvé
ça ailleurs j'ai même pas si on se
serait autant investi s'il n'y avait pas
eu la télé via l'atelier il ya des fois
des réceptions des réunions et tout est
l personnes qui sont presque
inaccessible pour nous c'est à dire les
maires les élus locaux et tout ça donc
grâce à l'atelier on a permis de ça nous
a permis de connaître ces gens là pour
une meilleure couverture du territoire
un autre centre d'affaires a vu le jour
à dammarie-les-lys coût total pour la
construction des deux structures un peu
plus de cinq cent mille euros financés à
50 % par des fonds européens
une est devenu essentiel pour soutenir
la création d'entreprises dans nos
territoires politique de la ville il ya
quand même 28 mille habitants une forte
population jeanne et qui parfois n'ont
pas forcément envie d'être salarié mais
souhaite
il ya un vrai potentiel un vrai vivier
une vraie énergie dans ces quartiers je
dirais que ça a eu un vrai effet levier
pour un prochain projet structurant sur
nos territoires
donc ça à valoriser c'est une belle
initiative
une belle initiative que l'atelier
espère concrétiser sur le long terme
objectif soutenir le développement de
200 projets en deux ans et ce type
d'initiative se développe aussi à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
l'agglomération fait partie à grégory
comme celle de melun val-de-seine des 15
idei présent en ile-de-france est ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer du coup ce
que veut dire ce terme de heat et heat
et nicolas cela signifie précisément
investissements territoriale intégrée
c'est un outil qui permet à la région
ile-de-france de coller au plus près à
la réalité aux besoins de chaque
territoire
cela peut être le développement
économique comme on vient de le voir
plus concrètement la région bénéficie de
540 millions d'euros de fonds européens
sur la période 2014 2020 et pour
dispatcher le plus efficacement possible
cette somme elle a sélectionné les
collectivités les plus à même
d'accompagner les porteurs de projets
elle saisit t y sont en fait un
intermédiaire entre la région qui est
autorité de gestion des fonds européens
les associations bailleurs et autres
entités qui souhaitent en bénéficier
alors on a vu en seine et marne en seine
et marne ces fonds ont permis de
financer des centres d'affaires dans
l'est dans les quartiers quels projets
ont été financés ici plus précisément à
saint quentin en yvelines
l'agglomération bénéficie d'une
enveloppe totale de 5 millions 200 mille
euros en qualité de territoire i t é
elle a déjà utilisé sur cette somme 2
millions d'euros dans des domaines assez
variés comme la rénovation de logements
pour lutter contre la précarité
thermique à guyancourt montigny le
bretonneux ou encore trappe des actions
menées aussi nicolas auprès des jeunes
élèves pour lutter contre la fracture
numérique un peu plus de 5 millions
d'euros 2 disponible pour 50 en yvelines
c'est une manne financière appréciable
en ces temps de disette pour les
collectivités et pour en savoir plus sur
ces sites et y investisse ments
territoriaux intégré vous pouvez
consulter les deux sites internet qui
s'affiche
en bas de vos écrans merci à grégory
pour toutes ces précisions
c'est la fin de ce premier set 8 europe
de la saison on se retrouve en octobre
pour une nouvelle émission
nous évoquerons notamment le programme
life un autre outil de financement de
l'union européenne pour des projets liés
à l'environnement et au changement
climatique cette fois ci à bientôt sur
l'antenne de tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à